all right so in baseball not that I'm
any kind of expert but of course you
know the pitcher gets signals from the
catcher yeah and he tells him what pitch
to throw and the catcher gets his
command from the coach so is the whole
thing going on in 2017 the Astros won
the World Series and now they figured
out that they had this investigation and
that the Houston Astros ran an elaborate
electronic sign stealing racket that
baseball has concluded gave them a legal
unfair advantage against the rest of the
league how did they find out about this
some player I don't know the whole story
what was the players name who you know
gave up the story Mike fiers Mike fiers
was being interviewed somewhere well he
was on the team won the World Series got
his ring then got traded to another team
and then he did an interview and he said
yeah we all cheated what was his
motivation in doing that because doesn't
he discredit his own team's win we
trying to figure out what his motivation
is you're right he just credits this
whole win maybe he was mad at them you
know maybe he wasn't it maybe he was
aware of it but didn't agree with it and
I don't know I can't I can't tell you
why he did it
I heard John Hine was all fired up about
like high energy John is fired up about
he calls the game around but is he a rat
or is he a hero he's saying look I want
cheating in your game hey why is he a
rat John what isn't he also a hero in
the sense that look okay yes he was
aware of it and he didn't say anything
at the time I agree that that's wrong
but he has a conscience and then yeah
but you're with these guys you're their
teammate a lot of stuff goes on on the
team when you're there that just isn't
spoken about and then two years later
out of nowhere he does this interview
and he's like yeah they were stealing
signs and here's how you don't do that
you don't do that to a former employer a
teammate he's got a world Syria but what
about all the guys who missed out on
let's say pay raises or because they
lost the World Series shouldn't they at
least be told the truth that they maybe
didn't really lose fairly there's a
couple things one the reason the Astros
won the World Series that year was not
because of this it helped absolutely how
do you know that
they won they clinched the World Series
in Los Angeles they weren't home they
were away but is there an advantage to
knowing that a fastball is coming
definitely definitely there is right
yeah I couldn't hit anything but you
told me what you were throwing but even
if you know curves coming you still got
to be able to hit it you know still need
to be able to actually execute what but
what they did Howard was so elaborate I
mean it was crazy the system where they
had a feed where they're supposed to use
in case you question a call like for the
for replay that was the reason it was in
there but what they did was they took it
use it to see what signs the other team
was using to call the pitches and then
they'd be sitting near the dugout and
someone would smash a garbage can to
signal what pitch was coming hi-tec yeah
so and it worked and Cora the guy who
went over to the Red Sox 2018 his team
won the World Series the next year so
clearly there's an advantage you are
anti whistleblower in other words you
feel the public should not know that
cheating occurred and and which cheating
will never stop and that means other
teams will get this advantage I think
that signs will always be stolen in
Major League Baseball's just hated
equipment oh here's my issue with fought
with Mike fiers okay okay if you were so
against this you where were you in 2017
why when you were on the team when you
were winning the ring when you were all
there why didn't you complain then
because he because that's like saying
hey because I was on the team I
shouldn't have a guilty conscience and
therefore I should note my mouth I mean
so he opened it up two years later but
still how do you know what he's been
living with you know maybe this just
didn't he couldn't keep it to himself
because it didn't go well with his
ethics I don't think you should be
cheating period okay but I don't think
if you're on that team you suddenly
decide to have a moral conscience two
years later after the fact to kind of
rat them out I think it's healthy for
baseball I think it's good that they're
cracking down on this but you know what
they're gonna figure out another way to
do it they're gonna get around it in a
different way that's just the ingenuity
of the players in the game I think
you're being a little off on this one
well the thing that drives me even
crazier I think you following this guy
around I'm calling him a guy a
whistleblower well he think I convinced
you but you don't want to admit no no
you make a fair point
and look again morally and ethically I
think you're right but when you're part
of a team and whatever is going on
there's a certain thing whether it's
your job wherever it might be ever it is
he wasn't strong enough to do it at the
time and he should he should have been
well but you could say coulda shoulda
but he was and so why did he want to put
debate high-pitch Eric he's got some
kind of coin okay I could you I don't
think constant on should manage the mess
because he used to be with the Astros
and he was probably involved in all of
us I said so here's my theory I feel is
that the astronaut on me because I don't
everything about baseball how did you
argue that Johnny into that I'm
speechless